das ist ein richtiger sensationsfund und
das gleich aus mehreren gründen der
riesige schwarze granit sarkophag ist
nicht nur alt sondern wohl auch der
größte sarkophag der jemals in
alexandria in ägypten entdeckt wurde
er wurde ende juni bei bauarbeiten in
fünf metern tiefe gefunden und
forschungsteams vermuten dass er seit
der antike nicht mehr geöffnet wurde
eine echte seltenheit jetzt wurde er
geöffnet im science fiction herzlich
willkommen
wenn ihre geschichten wie die mumie oder
mamis erkenntnis der dass dort
eindringlich davor gewarnt wird die
letzten ruhestätten der ägypter zu
stören doch das wissenschaftliche
interesse geht vor
denn es ist so so selten genug dass
gräber der antike gefunden werden die
noch ungeöffnet sind tatsächlich sind
die meisten von ihnen bereits vor
jahrhunderten von grabräubern geplündert
worden um kostbare grabbeigaben zu
klauen nicht so bei dem aktuellen fund
aus alexandria das amt ministerium hatte
am ersten juli verkündet dass bei
bauarbeiten in einem stadtteil nahm sie
die gabe der wohl größte derartige fund
in der region gemacht wurde der
sarkophag aus schwarzem gestein ist
ganze zwei meter 65 lang 1 meter 65
breit und 1 meter 85 hoch und zudem
scheint er wie gesagt ungeöffnet denn
die mittelschicht an den seiten des
deckels ist noch komplett intakt so
gehen forschungsteams davon aus dass er
wohl seit etwa 2000 jahren verschlossen
ist das ägyptische recht schreibt vor
dass jedes baugrundstück zunächst
gründlich von archäologen teams
untersucht werden muss was ein glück in
diesem fall experten und expertinnen
vermuten dass der sarkophag wohl aus der
zeit der ptolemäer stammt also von etwa
320 vor christus bis 30 vor christus in
der nähe des sarkophags wurde zudem eine
büste gefunden die sehr stark verwittert
ist ohne details erkennen zu können
geht man schwer davon aus dass sie den
verstorbenen darstellt und das lässt auf
einen mann schließen
doch wer genau könnte es sein ein
zeitgenosse von cleopatra der siebten
der letzten königin des bereichs und
außerdem die geliebte von gaius julius
caesar und marcus antonius manche hoffen
sogar darauf dass es sich um alexander
den großen handelt und zeitlich würde es
passen er starb wohl im juni 323 vor
christus und soll in alexandria begraben
worden sein
die experten und expertinnen schließen
von der größe des sarkophags darauf dass
es nicht nur den toten selbst sondern
auch grabbeigaben enthalten könnte diese
werden dann wohl auch verraten ob es
sich bei dem toten um einen hohen
würdenträger handelt oder eben nicht
doch jetzt war
die ernüchterung bei der eröffnung gross
keine grabbeigaben und auch nichts
deutet auf ein könig hin
der sarkophag ist unvollendet es gibt
keine liefen im sarkophag und das ist
die zweite enttäuschung wasser
wahrscheinlich über einen sehr langen
zeitraum aus den umgebenden gebäuden in
den sarkophag geschlossen außer knochen
von insgesamt drei toten enthält er
nichts und die geben rätsel auf einer
der toten wurde wohl von einem pfeil in
den kopf getroffen ein kämpfer die
anderen fleisch kameraden aber warum
dann ein so schwerer und großer
sauerland der deckel wie 15 tonnen
ja es bleiben mehr fragen als antworten
und wenn ihr kein video zu diesen und
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er
die kaputte abo boxer auf youtube und
verpasst kein video game awards erfahrt
ihr von mir persönlich vor jedem upload
also vor jedem upload auf youtube
also ihr kriegt den link einfach zuerst
und zwar vor allen anderen täglich und
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks und social media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der social media
welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht mehr
wisse dass die genau glocke vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken geheime kammer in der jobs
pyramide bis dann bleibt dran